All right. Well, it is 900 PM in New
York, 700 p.m. out here in Montana, and
it is my pleasure to welcome Professor
Gang to our abode, our discussion. So,
uh, Professor Gang, I I hope I didn't
mangle your name. If I did, that's on
me. But, uh, welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> Great.
So, first off, before we start this
discussion, I'd like to let you
introduce yourself to our group. So, you
have an interesting history
um in both China and Canada and um just
give us a little taste of your personal
story.
>> Yeah, great. Um so, thanks so much for
inviting me, Richard. So, my name is
Professor Tang. Um I was born in China.
Uh and then when I was six, my family
and I immigrated to Toronto, Canada for
better opportunities. Um my father had
just experienced the cultural revolution
and he didn't want me to experience that
um as well. So we went over um my father
was a high school teacher in China, but
he didn't really speak English. So um
when he went over to Canada, he became a
dishwasher, restaurant cook for the rest
of his life. He's retired now. Um, and
uh, I grew up in Toronto, but um, I
worked very hard and I I got a
scholarship to study at Yale University.
I was an English major there. And um, I
wanted to go to law school because
that's what you do after you graduate
from Yale. Um, but I wanted to take a
break before going to law school. So I I
came over to Beijing, China to teach
English um, at a high school
>> for a couple years. And I loved it. I
fell in love with education. I fell in
love with teaching. I've I've tried
different careers. I've I've worked as a
journalist. I've worked as a filmmaker.
I I've also worked for the United
Nations in Afghanistan. So, I I've had a
pretty ecatic career. Um but I've always
loved education. So, um um when I was in
my early 30s, I returned to education in
China and I've worked in different
capacities. I was a high school
principal. I was a curriculum director.
I was a teacher trainer. And now I am
just a regular high school teacher
because I have three kids. I have three
young kids. and um I need I need to
spend time with my kids. So, I returned
to the classroom and um um but I've
always wanted to teach the liberal arts.
So, as a high school teacher um I teach
the great books um the Iliad, the
Odyssey, the Divine Comedy, the
Republic, the Bible, um the INIAD,
Paradise Lost. So, I I teach all the
great books basically and um
>> of the Western is what it sounds like.
>> Right. Right. So, I don't teach Chinese
canon because I I don't my Chinese isn't
good enough. Um but I I teach the
western cannon
>> and um eventually I started to teach
history as well because I I recognized
that in China you can't really teach the
western cannon without the context
without um teaching western history and
I started to upload my um lectures to
YouTube uh because I wanted to share my
ideas with a larger audience
>> and for the first year I got 300
subscribers and I was really excited
about that. Um, I I had I had great
interactions with uh the audience and
then um a couple months ago my my
channel blew up. Um I'm I'm about over
600 600,000 subscribers now on YouTube.
So it's been a wild ride. Uh but but but
but it's only been the past two three
months. Um my channel's been getting a
lot of attention and um and yeah, so so
that's that's where we are right now. Uh
my channel is called predictive of
history and some of you may may know the
channel but the idea is I want to
reimagine history the way it's taught
the way that is conceived and so my uh
biggest concern about history is that
it's not analytical it's not structured
um there's too much focus on individuals
there's too much focus on storytelling
and not and not enough on the analysis
of structural forces that drive history
and so um my project uh it's a huge
project. But my project is to reimagine
history as a tool for us to better
understand humanity um as well as to
predict the future. So the goal is to go
back and reinterpret history so to
accomplish three goals. The first goal
is that we're able to create a coherent
story about humanity. Second goal is to
help us better understand the present to
explain the present. And the third goal
is to give us the tools to predict the
future.
>> So that's why it's called predict
history. Yeah.
>> Yes. I've been digesting your content um
really over the past month, but even
especially over the past um few days,
and I've really enjoyed it. And yeah, I
think you've become sort of a Jordan
Peterson-like figure. Jordan Peterson
was a rather obscure uh psychologist in
Canada uploading lectures and it caught
on. And I hope that I hope the exact
same thing happens with you. Um, I I
>> But but but but but I don't want the
like the manic episode, right? I like
like like I want to avoid the
>> Well, we would expect you to cry during
this interview at some point. Just all
your emotions. Yeah, that's the way
that's the path to the top.
>> I'll try my best. I'll try my best. But
yeah,
>> uh but okay, let's jump into history
because you know Henry Ford said history
is bunk. Uh history is a slaughter
bench. there there is so much violence
and irrationality things about history
you can't find any meaning in I think
for a lot of people history is a story
um maybe even a moral story you can um
learn about George Washington and the
cherry tree and become a better person
um Hegel you know history is reason
marching uh forward and becoming
self-conscious of itself or something
like that uh so there there's been there
there's been attempts I would say that
for most people history is detail um
maybe it's wars diplomats uh etc. But I
mean your try to help us understand like
where where you're coming from because I
mean is it a a sort of deterministic
account almost it's not Marxist of
course but but somewhat like Markx like
there there's class dynamics that are at
play that are pushing us towards this
and scientifically we can understand it
or or give us a taste of how we could
learn from the past and predict the
future and better understand you know
dynamics in the present
>> right okay um that's a great question
and my answer is going to be long-winded
so I apologize in advance
>> but um before I started to teach history
I actually spent some time teaching
computer science um so I spent quite
some time understanding artificial
intelligence and how it worked so and I
became obsessed with how artificial
intelligence works but the idea about
artific artificial intelligence is that
you can create a feedback back loop so
that the output becomes the input. Um,
and what I mean by that is rather than
you write the algorithm, rather than you
write the code and try to figure out how
something happens, what you do is you
you let the machine figure out uh the
variables, the forces that create the
outcome. So, so, so you train the
machine with the outcome, with the
results, and then the machine tries to
figure out how we got to these results.
Um and that's how how artificial
intelligence works. So um so my great
insight is well we we can do the same
thing with history. Um because every um
understanding of history it is really an
analytical model right it's an
understanding of how the world works.
There are values there assumptions
embedded in your model. And because it's
an analyical model, it has to be also a
a predictive model because you you're
assuming that that these values, these
assumptions will say consistent, right?
So, so my argument is this.
If history if if a historical
understanding is correct, then we can
analyze it and create predictions of the
future. And these predictions will allow
us to validate or negate the model. At
the very least it will allow us to
better understand the model and then to
refine the model. So I so I'll give you
an an easy example. So if you look at
how history is written the assumption is
it is te theological meaning that we are
progressing towards um a greater good or
things are improving. And if you just to
look at what's happening today clearly
the theological model doesn't work
because how would you explain um all
these wars that are raging around the
world? How would you explain what's
happening in the Middle East? How would
you explain all this civil conflict and
economic males in the United States? How
would you explain the the the the
election of Donald Trump? So I don't
think history is theological. Um so so
so I think that the current um the the
world how the world's progressing, it
sort of negates that theological model.
But but but so so so that's that's how I
think about history. Mhm. Well, do you
do you think it's thus cyclical or
or is is that more on your wavelength or
>> Yeah. So, I think it's very important um
to always keep to have like different
possibilities. Um so, as you as you
mentioned historically, the debate has
always been is it is history linear,
theological or is it cyclical? Um and it
just rhymes. It's bound to repeat
itself. And um
um I've been working on a new theory uh
recently and I'll just present to you
but but but I warn you that it is a very
um immature undeveloped theory but but
my theory is that history is develop is
is sort of um underpinned by narratives
by sacred stories. Um, and so what
history really is, it's about humanity's
attempt to achieve certain stories that
they believe to be sacred and to be true
in itself. And um, that's what drives
um, societies, that's what drives
history. Um, you can another say another
way of saying this is that history is
almost esquetological,
>> right? So you have people obsessed with
the second coming of Jesus and for them
it's like how do we create the
conditions
for the return of Jesus
>> and you can make the argument that
that's what's really driving the
conflict in the Middle East. You have um
these mi mi mi m me m me m me m me m me
m me m me m me m me m meisianic um Jews.
You have these Christian Zionists who
are obsessed with creating World War II
because in their minds that will compel
the return of Jesus to restore peace in
the world and create the meic
millennium. Okay, that's that's what
they think.
>> And so my argument is that it's that
perception is reality. Belief is
reality. So if enough people in power
believe something, they can make it
real. And that's what drives history.
It's narrative that creates reality.
It's stories that create the world we
live in today.
>> Well, and in mind before matter, which
is something you talked about in your
your lectures on the development of
polytheism to monotheism, uh, etc. we we
do seem to assume that, you know,
there's a brain, a clump of gray matter
and and cells and so on and and and a
mind develops from that. Um the ancients
thought something very different. And I
and as an analogy, you you could think
about that in terms of world history
that there's some great story that is
being retold over and over again. We're
telling it to ourselves and that story
is informing in ways we can't fully
understand maybe unconsciously our
decisions and actions and sometimes even
even consciously. I mean there there's
no doubt that you know we you can look
back to the middle ages and see a great
deal of stasis. Nothing much happened at
le I shouldn't say that of course many
things happened but nothing much changed
there there wasn't a sense of
development in people's minds and maybe
that had something to do with the fact
that this world I is just a a waiting
room that this world doesn't matter your
your best life is later on so there's
really you you can build monuments
pointing upwards towards towards God but
there's no real reason to develop
anything right now because th this is
we're going to shuffle off this mortal
coil and um and live in eternity with
God. And so there's no reason to
develop. Um I mean I'm I'm also thinking
here of um political theology and which
we could define as the um every
political ideology
um attempt at legitimacy is a
secularization of an earlier religion.
And so there is something deeply
Christian to the modern world and in and
obviously people were more sinc per
perhaps sincere Christians in the middle
ages but we've in a way attempted to
actualize it in modernity in the sense
that we're pushing towards heaven on
earth um we're we're pushing towards a
new humanity uh etc. And you you can
obviously see that in um revolutionary
movements, the French Revolution, the
American Revolution, even um certainly
in the development of communism. Um we
are it. We're going to this whole
slaughter bench of history is going to
end with us. And and and there's a deep
Christian core to that type of thinking.
And and so on once that thinking is
embedded in a mind then historical
actors whether they be politicians or
warriors or scientists are are going to
conform to that that idea. Um and and so
it's a sort of explanation of human
action. There's there's a narrative
behind it. It's it's not all just
individual will and rationality that
we're trying to fulfill something
that that's been in our brains since we
were children. We're trying to fulfill
that in this world.
>> Yeah, I completely agree. I mean that's
um I mean um I mean that's exactly
right. Um I I think the the major phrase
that resonates is heaven on earth. And
um I think that's a major break from the
past where where where as you say before
um we always assume that this was just a
stop on a on a on a journey an internal
journey through the heavens and we're
here to um experience certain things we
could not experience um up in the
heavens because here we have corporal
bodies. We're physical but up there we
are spiritual. Um so so th this this is
a place it's part of the journey but
it's not the end of of the journey. Um
and everything we do here is to prepare
ourselves for the journey out there
which which is what really matters and
as you say um this past hundred years I
mean it really with the beginning of
modernity right uh with Freud and with
Einstein and with General Wolf James
Joyce our mindset has changed so that we
believe that we are we are heaven and we
can create heaven on earth and that's
that's really an entire
>> project of western civilization of our
journey today to use science um to use
psychology to use economics to create a
paradise on on Earth. And on one hand,
you know, that's that's that that's
extremely idealistic. But on the other
hand, it's also very scary because you
can argue that um we're playing God. And
so so you see the rise of artificial
intelligence, you see the rise of
eugenics, you see um I mean um
communism, right? I mean like these are
all attempts to create heaven and earth.
Um but but the underlying assumption is
that we can be God and any Christian
will tell you that that that's actually
very dangerous to to to think.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Um do you think maybe
maybe so much of the disappointment and
heartache
that we we see in everyday life, no
one's happy, and I'm speaking as an
American. Um, you can talk to people on
the left. Uh, on the right, the the left
will love that Luigi Manion shot that
fat bastard who had too much money and
and was keeping healthcare from the
people. Uh, the right are are in a sort
of state of paranoia in in many ways
about uh the deep state and and the
government and people trying to turn
them transsexual and and so on. There
there there's a general unhappiness. And
I I was wondering if that had something
to do with the fact that we've sort of
lost a story, the story of the 20th
century. We we don't quite have it
anymore. We don't have that utopia that
we're pushing towards. And let let me
just throw out one example that that's
more concrete.
um Brev, the um premier of the Soviet
Union, gave a speech at one point in the
19, I believe in the late '7s, and he
said something to the effect, well, Carl
K Carl Marx wasn't about fairy tales. He
was a scientist. And so, we're not quite
yet at communism. We're still in the
socialist stage, but we're, you know,
through bureaucratic excellence moving
step by step in that direction. And
within 15 years, the whole thing came
crashing down. And I think maybe he he
got it wrong in the sense that Karl Marx
is a fairy tale actually at some point.
He is telling you a story about the past
and this amazing world to come that
actually inspires you to sacrifice and
to, you know, look to the stars and
imagine a new world. And the moment the
Soviet Union lost that was the moment
that it started to actually come
crashing down. And I I think there's a
lot of similarities in the United States
with Brev as as Joe Biden, these these
old men in charge of this thing. They're
sort of calling back to the past,
calling back to the the Cold War, but
they're not really looking ahead. And um
so I I I guess what I'm what I'm getting
at is is maybe like that that loss of
that utopian desire might really be at
the heart of the
>> disappointment that that we see
everywhere. It's you you'll see it in
your neighbors. You'll see it on far
leftists. You'll see it on conservative
activists activists. They they all seem
to agree that it hasn't worked out, that
it's getting worse, and that it's not
headed anywhere.
>> Yeah. Um I completely agree. So um I'll
give you a counter example to what's
happening in the western world. You look
at the Houthis in Yemen, okay?
>> Uh these are people been poor all their
lives. They have no access to
technology. Um they might have some
ballistic missiles brought up from Iran,
but I mean like they're still a pretty
low technology society. They're very
they're very poor. Um but I guarantee
you like the people the Houthies in
Yemen, they're probably happier. the um
they're a lot a lot happier than uh
Americans um and and there are certain
reasons why I mean first of all
>> they're extremely spiritual people right
I mean like like they are I mean they
are Shia they I mean they really believe
in their religion there there's a
unifying story there's unifying
mythology to their society that's the
first point the second point is that
they're living for a higher purpose
>> um they I I don't think they're being
political or manipulative or calculating
when they say that they care about
what's happening in Gaza and they will
not stop um until Israel stops what's
happening in Gaza. I I I think they're
being extremely sincere. And the third
thing is, you know, death gives me war
and death gives meaning to people.
>> Um you know, we you know, America,
Western society h has created a society
that fears death, that thinks that death
is the worst thing that can happen to
you. And as a result, people aren't
taking risks. people are don't have the
freedom, the liberty to ch to they don't
have agency anymore. And I I I don't so
I think that if you don't have
community, you don't have purpose, you
don't have agency, it's very hard to
live a happy, creative, and meaningful
life. And and and that's the fundamental
issue facing not just America, but all
of Western society today.
>> Um yes, absolutely. So let's
let's talk about the Middle East here
because it's it's not just a region of
the world and it's also not just a
region of world in which there are
immense stores of petroleum. Those are
obviously important things. Uh but it's
also the Holy Land. It's the story told
in the Torah uh about a small people uh
escaping persecution under Pharaoh and
living in the wilderness and then
ultimately marching into Canaan,
establishing a kingdom at some point and
go and going through all sorts of
adventures and and ups and downs uh
along the way. So it it has theological
importance. I mean, even with someone,
you know, who's in the news now, Charlie
Kirk, they they would, you know, say,
"What what are your thoughts on Israel?"
And so on. He's like, "Well, you know,
gosh, I feel like there's a lot of
violence and ethnic cleansing, but just
keep in mind, this is where Jesus walked
on water and raised people from the
dead, and turned water into wine." It it
had this emotional
contact with him. And and and thus, I
don't think he could have he could ever
give it up. um because it's it's on that
level of his being. Um but but how do we
understand because I mean you you look
at the Middle East now, it's blood and
guts. Uh obviously Israel is engaging in
an ethnic cleansing of the Palestinians.
Um there are tons of massations going on
and etc. It looks chaotic. Um but how do
we understand it in in terms of a story
of uh from the Bible um or uh or or a
theology?
>> Yeah. So um Jerusalem has been at the
heart of human history for a long long
time. Um and um there are many reasons
why right. So so you mentioned the
esquetological theological religious
element. Okay. And we'll we'll talk
about that later on. But we also we also
remember that throughout human history
this region the lavant was really the
center the epicenter of global trade. I
mean you wanted to go from Egypt to
Anatolia to Mesopotamia to Europe you
had to go through the lavant. So uh the
lot was always contested territory and
you know back in in those days whoever
control the trade routes was was the
empire of that day and and that's why um
Israel has featured prominently
throughout human history and and that's
why you know if you are an uh Israelite
you really did believe that you were
center of the world because everyone was
trying to grab your your your territory.
>> Um and as you say today now now there
there all this oil in the Middle East.
So, so you you make the argument that
from a historical perspective, the
Leavant really is the center of the
world. Um, certainly what what happens
at Leavant is what drives human history.
Um, so but to answer your question like
like like if you talk about the
esquetological elements, um, people
believe that Jerusalem is the holy city
and I'm not sure if you've been to
Jerusalem. Um I I've been to Jerusalem
for one day and it is really um the most
beautiful, the most sacred, the most
holy city in the world. I mean I mean
like you just walk the city, you can
feel all that holy energy. I mean I mean
it it really is um in a deeply spiritual
experience if you're open to that sort
of thing and just walk the streets of
Jerusalem and it's a really really small
place. It's really cramped. But the sort
of like religious devotion, the
religious energy in that small area,
it's just immense, right? It's a meeting
place of many different religions. Um
you have the theat moss, you have the
church of the holy separ, you you have
of course the um the western wall. Um so
so it so from religious perspective,
it's really the epicenter of the world.
So I think it's natural for people to
believe that this is where history began
and this is where history will end,
right? like and history ends with the
second coming of Jesus.
>> And that's what people are praying for.
And what's really important for us to
understand is it's not just the Jewish
faith. It's many faiths. You have the
Islamic faith who believe that Judaism
will be um the second will will will be
the end of the world. You have the
Orthodox, you have the Catholic, you
have um all these different faiths um
that that all converge on Jerusalem. And
so um you know my my thesis is that
narrative drives history and because the
second coming is such a powerful
narrative. People are drawn to that
place, but but not only only are they
drawn to that place, but they feel
compelled by that they're compelled by
their faith to act out their belief and
that story is very very compelling like
a world war in which Israel stands up
against the entire world. Um the war of
Gog and Magog uh Armageddon and this
will lead to the age with Jesus returns.
I mean if you just like like what like
I'm not a religious person but but I did
say the literature and I I I can tell
you that just from a literary
perspective it's a beautiful moving
compelling story that d that compels
people into action it's very inspiring
um and it's really the most powerful
story in the world that like through our
actions for our sacrifice we can achieve
heaven on earth we can achieve the
messianic age and if you just act out
the script then everything will be fine
I I I I mean it it really is the
greatest drama. It really is the
greatest movie and you can be a
participant in it. And and and and so so
I think that's that that's what's going
on in the Middle East. And so if this
theory is correct, then then we go then
we make certain predictions about what
will happen in the Middle East. Well,
first of all, what's happening in Gaza
um is certainly part of the esquetology.
Um, right. Because what's happening in
Gaza, it's really, I mean, driving the
world against Israel. I mean, like like
if if you just say a normal human being
and you see what Israel is doing in
Gaza, you can't be you can't feel um but
you can't feel but be disgusted and and
contemptuous for what's happening. So
that that's number one. I think that
what's happening in Gaza will over the
next few months speed up. I I know it's
what's happening is terrible is terrible
right now, but they can do so much
worse. And you know,
>> they can outright seize the territory
for one thing. Yes.
>> And that's what they're doing. Um, you
know, and and I I I think they've cut
off internet access so the world does
not really know what's going on there
any anymore. Um they they've launched a
massive offensive in Gaza and Nam has
come and said that we need to be Sparta,
you know, we need to come together as a
military society to achieve the
prophecy. Okay. So I think what's
happening in Gaza will just speed up
over next few months. Okay, that's
number one. Number two is and and I
think number two is what's what what's
going to shock the world is eventually
they will destroy the alac mosque uh
because that that's part part of their
esquetology
>> and and and and so I mean like like like
so the thing about religion is astrology
and numerology really matter so they
have the date okay they they they know
exactly when they will do this um all
the preparations are in place but
because I don't have access to their um
numerology I mean like so So, so it's um
I um it's part of the Cabala, you know,
they have this like numerology,
astrology. So, so they they have these
people who spent years figuring out the
exact date to destroy the AXC mosque
because because that's because that that
is the most u opportune or the most
heavenly the most divine time. So, they
have that date. I don't I don't know. I
I don't know what is. I'm sure that if
you have some expectation in the cabala
um and you do some digging, you can
figure out that date. But they have that
date and they will destroy that all of
mass and it will come out of nowhere. I
mean it might just be a rocket coming
out of nowhere and blow that that thing
up. I I don't know how they'll do it but
it's going to shock the world and that's
the intention to shock the world. Um so
I think that and I think it will be h it
will happen really quickly because they
have the red heer in place. So I'm not
sure if you know much about
>> Yes. No, I I do. Yes.
>> So they have the red heer, right? and
and and like like they had I think a one
or two year time frame in order to
actually sacrifice the red heer to
consecrate the third temple. So it's
going to happen within the next next two
years.
>> Well, according to this fellow on Tim
Pool, the red heer has been sacrificed.
In fact, I don't know if you saw that.
>> Uh okay.
>> Yeah. Make of it what you will. Um, yes,
this this person named King who's who's
wellconed on the right wing and and he's
a super Jew of of some kind. Uh, he
announced that the red heer actually had
been ritualistically sacrificed. Uh,
yeah, Adam King is his name. Uh, and so
this is happening now. He announced that
on Tim P's show. I mean, make of that
what you will. Maybe he's a a dreamer,
but uh, clearly something is happening.
Th this isn't just some uh biblical
story. Th this is something that they're
directly pursuing. And let let me get
also to to something just to um to to
put some emphasis on this notion of
being hated. So
>> Jews are well accustomed to being hated.
If you look at the stories that they
tell of themselves,
uh there is always a pharaoh somewhere
who is going to oppress them, enslave
them, and not let them leave. And that
could be uh a rather benign pharaoh like
the Wasp establishment. That could be a
terrible pharaoh like Hitler. Uh that
that could be um 19th century
anti-semitism and forcing them to get
us, etc., etc. There's there's always a
story of persecution and the stories
throughout the Bible. Now, obviously
there's David's kingdom, there's there's
triumph and Canaan, but Genesis, um,
most all of Exodus, it's it's about
persecution. They're used to it. Their
>> Yeah.
>> identity is based in part and to a large
part on being hated. So, in in some
ways, I I think what I'm hearing here is
that first off, they're used to it.
Second off, they might want to jin it
up. They they're okay with being hated.
They're okay with being with having the
world turn on them. And that in fact is
a great source of identity. If there's
anti-semit, you know, Mumami in New York
City mayor, I'm not sure how
anti-Semitic that guy is, but at least
the story is you've got to flee. you've
got to get out of there. Come to Israel.
You know, America Trump, Donald Trump's
the new Hitler. Come to Israel. There so
much of their identity um works through
that type of dynamic. And so doing
something as shocking as as destroying
this mosque in Jerusalem.
>> It it's it's part of the game plan.
>> Yeah. I and I mean I mean again I think
that if you just dabble in the cabala if
you just study a bit of numerology
um you you will discover like it's it's
always been part of the plan to blow to
blow that thing up but but but you know
it has to be blown up at a certain time.
Um I I'm very skeptical that they've
sacrificed the red heer because they
will sacrifice a red heer in order to
consecrate the third temple. So you
first need to destroy that as mos and
then you need to consecrate that the
land that that the territory so the
priest can go in and build that that
third temple. I mean it they're very
very specific. I mean they're really
ritualistic. They have to follow things
exactly for for for they have to think
follow things exactly that that that's
part of part part of their religion. I
mean it's a very priestly religion. Uh
they're extremely ritualistic. They're
extremely u obsessive compulsive. So I
don't think they they they sacrificed
it. Um they they would not screw up the
timeline like that. But
>> your larger point about you know Jews
and creating hatred in order to create a
sort of like ethnic identity for
themselves. Um, so I'm not sure how much
you know about uh Jewish history, but
but but but I'll give you my overall
framework of how I understand Jewish
history. So I mean obviously the golden
age for the Jews was the King of David.
And at that time in history, and we're
talking like maybe 10,00 BC um um uh BCE
um this is this is after the Bronze Age
collapse. Mhm.
>> Um, Israel um, as a nation um, as a
people and as depicted in the Bible,
it's it's it's it's wealthy, it's open,
it's cosmopolitan. And if you actually
look at the history, it was also
polytheistic. Montheism is something
that's something that comes after the
Babylon exile. But at that point, it was
an extremely open poly polytheistic
welcome society. But over time because
the Leavan is such contested territory
um more and more empires start to invade
um Israel and carved up uh Israel in
different different territories. You had
the um Assyrians, you had the Bab the
Babylonians
um and and ultimately it led to the
Babylonian exile and and that's what and
that's where most scholars believe the
Bible was actually written or most of it
was redacted. And so at this point in
history, you have these the elite who
are who are deprived of their people and
their land and their religion, right?
Because Jerusalem is the holy city,
right? And you're in you're stuck in
Babylon somewhere. And so they they now
have to reconceive, reimagine their
religion in a way that allows them to
stay united um as a powerless diaspora
um that um that has no access to their
god and to to holy land. And um you know
with Cyrus the great um the great
Messiah in the Bible, he was he sent the
Jews back to uh to Jerusalem to to build
um the temple, but it was under Persian
patronage. Um and then after Persians
came um the Greeks um the the the the uh
columnies in Egypt and then and the the
the uh Seucid Empire. So throughout most
of this history um the the Jews were
tools of empire and and so at so what's
happening is that they need to
constantly reimagine their religion in a
way that saves them that allows them to
stay united um against all this
oppression and that's why over time the
religion became much more conservative
much more close-minded and much more
fanatical
um and then of course you have the rise
of Christianity and Christianity was a
great threat to the religion
because a lot of Jews were absorbed into
the religion and now you have basically
a civil war going on in the Jewish
religion and now and and now how h how
do you maintain your religion under the
threat of Christianity and of course
Islam will will arise later and then and
then you have certain traumatic events
like the Spanish um um expulsion when
when when Jews were asked either to
convert or to leave Spain and go to the
Ottoman Empire and what the trauma was
Most Jews chose to convert. And so
throughout history, the Jews had a
problem. It's like, how do you stay
united? And what they discovered is the
best way to stay united is by creating
opposition against the dominant
community uh by by doing things by um
creating events that um create
differentiation that that basically
create cause the larger community to
despise you. Um and um and and and if we
move fast forward to the modern age, uh
you can argue that Zionism, the creation
of Zionism, it's fueled by anti-semitism
because, you know, at the end of the
20th century, sorry, at the end of 19th
century when Theodore Herszel wrote
wrote his book, right, that that began
Zionism
>> like like everyone thought it was crazy
like Jews didn't were happy in Europe,
they were happy in Britain, they're
happy in America. Why would they want to
go go to a desert in Israel? like like
at that time in history and this around
1900 only about 3% of Jews even
considered
>> moving back to the Holy Land. Okay, only
3% and and they're considering this.
They're actually doing this, right? So
so so now you have a problem like like
how do you get these Jews to go back to
Israel? Because without Israel because
you don't have Jews going back to
Israel, then the the Israel project
doesn't really work. You you cannot
reconstitute the Holy Land. Mhm.
>> And so you you make the argument that at
at that time they develop certain
strategies that would ignite anyism in
around the world in order to force Jews
to uh uh return to Jerusalem. And and
and this is not a conspiracy theory.
Okay. There there's a Jewish historian
in Israel, Israeli historian Ellen Pap,
who's written many books. This
discussing the rise of Zionism and how
it's fueled by terrorist acts um against
Jewish people that were false flags. Um
this happened in Baghdad where where
there's a very vibrant uh Jewish
community and they were happy in
Baghdad. Okay. But then you had certain
um terrorist activities that forced them
to to leave um um Baghdad and return to
Jerusalem. And and and I mean and and I
mean in Pap will go as far as to say
that there was certain collaboration
between Zionists and the Nazis during
World War II because the Nazis wanted to
remove Jews from Germany and the Zionist
wanted the Jews to return to to to
Jerusalem. So it makes sense that they
would collaborate in in in capacities,
>> right?
Yes. And there's a Herzel attempted to
win over Wilhelm II, I believe. And
yeah, and I think he said the famous
quote of anti-semites will be our best
friends in a way because our our uh you
know interests are aligned. Um but this
project which is still under 80 years. I
mean
modern Israel they brag about being a
tech society the Silicon Valley of the
Middle East. It's a modern democracy
surrounded by theocracies. They've
they've sort of sold themselves as
secular. But as you're saying, embedded
in that is a grander biblical Jewish
project of bringing about the Messiah, I
guess, in their minds for the first
time.
>> Yeah. Well, I mean, I mean, like most
societies, I mean, Israel is suffering
from an identity crisis. So as you say
um there are place like Tel Aviv that is
very open, very liberal, very
cosmopolitan that that's really where uh
the tech sector is based and um you know
they're very aligned with reformed Jews
in America. So they're very liberal
orientation and they see Netanyahu as
really Satan. I mean um but these past
10 years it's really these extremist
Jews. Um and many of them are uh 17
Frankus. I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the ideas of um uh sabotage Zevi
and uh Jacob Frank. Um but they really
believe that through transgression,
through committing evil, through um
doing sin, you can accelerate biblical
prophecy and create them as an age. Um
and and these figures are very dominant
in Israel, but they're also very
dominant um in America and around the
world. Um so I'm I'm not sure uh but if
you're interested, it's very important
that um you study Zeppat Zevi and Jacob
Frank. Um their their philosophy because
um their big philosophy is redemption
through sin. that by creating even the
world you can actually um create the
conditions for a better world and and
and and and so these are uh extremists
embedded within the dynamic cabinet that
want to drive the um the end times. So
it's possible you have a million
Israelis who are liberal, who are
open-minded, but you only need about 10
to who who are in positions of power and
who are complete align in trying to
achieve esquetology.
Those 10 can cause a lot of damage. And
I think it those 10 people, a very small
minority of people that's driving
Israeli policy right now. No, a lot of
the reason why is because they have the
mass support of Christian Zionists in
the United States as well as in Britain
and and around the world.
>> Well, also just uh you know a data point
here. So right now actually Peter Teal
who is a a Silicon Valley master of the
universe is giving a lecture series on
the antichrist. This is something that
he referenced in some major interviews
he did, one with the New York Times and
and others. He he seems to associate the
antichrist with uh Greta Thunberg of all
people uh who's going to force us all to
live in a eco-fascist village or or
something like that that she's going to
promise us safety and security but also
identity. So it's it's it's Greta as the
antichrist. I don't think it's any
coincidence that Greta also as we speak
is uh on a flotillaa or is is traveling
to Gaza and has been maybe the most
famous outspoken critic against
Netanyahu uh and and such. I I think
those those ideas rhyme together. Um,
now most of Teal's critics would say
that he's the antichrist because he sort
of fits the image and he's bringing on
the surveillance state and and and so
on. And I I sort of understand where
they're coming from with that. But but
how does the how does that idea of the
antichrist, anti- messiah, false messiah
fit into this story?
>> Yeah. So um the antichrist is a very
important concept in esquetology. They
have different there. And so um the
first thing to understand about the
antichrist is if you look at different
esquetologies whe whether it's orthodox
or Christian or Jewish it's not a person
it's actually
>> different people um so so it's possible
like you will have different antichrist
emerge
um over time. Okay that's the first
thing. Second thing is that um it's not
really who the antichrist is. what he
does, right? Because the idea of the
antichrist is that he creates a unified
government that brings about the
surveillance state, the mark of the
beast they call it, right? The the like
like the mark of the beast you can
interpret as possibly a social security
number. Um but also a microchip in in in
your in your head or or or whatever, but
but something that
>> marks you for for life and allows the
surveillance surveillance state to to
control you. Um different people have
interpreted uh the antichrist to mean
the United Nations to create a a a a
world government. Um so but but but
whatever the esquetology uh what they
say is the antichrist has to come first
before the meic age. Um and so it would
make sense like the focus is not on the
antichrist because once once you create
the antichrist then you create the
conditions for the me age. So what's
really important for us to remember is
that there's a script in place
>> and so we can actually predict how
they'll behave
>> because for them it's really important
that you follow the script to the
letter. Uh you know they're just actors.
God is is director. They're just actors
and they have to act out the script
precisely in order to create the
conditions for the magical age the the
millennium they call it heaven on on on
earth bas basically. Um so I'm sorry
about being vague but the antichrist is
interpreted differently in different
esquetologies.
Well, uh, you know, when we think of the
the Antichrist as well, I was, have you
ever looked into the work of, uh, Yakim
or Wim Deior? Um, he's he's a
>> Okay. Well, I'll I'll I'll set it up. Um
regardless he it's 12th and 13th century
monk and he in many ways brought about
the idea of not just a sort of linear
progression in history but a a
dispensation.
And so there's the age that is depicted
in the Old Testament um that is the age
of the father and it's harsh,
brutal. There's death, there's
punishment, there's destroying the world
and so on. And there's the age of the
sun that is Jesus coming and it's it it
is about a sacrifice of the sun in order
to wash away the tears of that earlier
age and he was a again he was you 12th
13th century so he was sort of living a
thousand years after Jesus um you know
right smack dab in in the high middle
ages I guess and he saw even figures
blank Frederick II in uh from the Holy
Roman Empire, this German uh uh king as
a kind of antichrist figure. He was uh
usurping the pope uh going to the holy f
he he was I don't know the maybe the
Trump of his age or Hitler I don't know
exactly but what he thought is that a
figure like that who's challenging all
authority is necessary to bring on the
third age which he viewed as the age of
the Holy Spirit and it was in a in a
weird way and perhaps I'm projecting a
reading on here But in a in a funny way
it was it was almost a time without God
because you know the age of the father
is passed the patriarchy the age of
Jesus when we were redeemed through
suffering and sacrifice that's also
passed and now we're in an age of a holy
of the Holy Spirit in which the world
will become a giant monastery
and we we in we're going to spend all of
our lives helping one another. You could
say it's a giant hospital. That's
actually Nietze had a costic line of
socialism and liberalism. You want to
create a gigantic hospital where we're
all sick and we're just taking care of
one another. Obviously, he didn't want
anything like that, but that's sort of
what he's describing. He's basically
describing communism. I mean, the
monastery is a communistic ideal.
There's no competition. There there
there's no antagonism. There's there's
helping and sharing. and and and so he
he was sort of the I guess you could
almost weirdly say the first Marxist or
the the first progressive, the first
liberal in a way. Um and and it shows
how deep these ideas are. This notion of
dispensationalism, we think it comes
from the Scoffield Bible or something.
It's very deep.
>> Um and and the notion of a pro a
progress towards an end of history and
an end of suffering, that's really deep
in Western history. that's not just some
new idea. It's it's embedded within us
like a Russian nesting doll. Um, but I
guess what I was saying is that, you
know, the the there has to be an
antichrist figure for this to happen.
You you have to sort of go through the
night before there's a dawn. There has
to be some antagonistic
man of sin who is opposed to Christ and
in order for the Christ to arise. And
and so again I I think this sort of you
know creating hatred creating the
problem so that you can have the
solution th this also goes way back.
>> Yeah. No you're exactly right. Um so
yeah as you say the sculfield bible um
historians will tell you the scul of
bible is what started Christian zionism
in the uh United States. But you
actually look at the history of zionism.
It actually started in England and it
was the secret societies Freemasonry
that actually brought Christian Zionism
into u America and some are even argue
like Christian Zionism was embedded in
um in in the founding of America. I mean
like like and that's really why America
rebelled again against Britain in order
to create a theocracy in in order to
achieve um Christian Zionism. So
Christianism goes
>> the new Jerusalem. Yeah. As they
>> That's right. Exactly. Um so so all this
goes way way back. Um
and Scoffield Bible I mean you can also
argue it is a scop right to the British
Scoffield Bible in order to spread
Christian Zionism to the public because
Christian Zionism was embedded in in
these secret societies but but now you
need to popularize Christian Zionism. I
mean you did it for the school of Bible.
Um, so, so you can argue like they've
been doing this for centuries. Like
there are these hidden hands, secret
societies that have been doing this for
centuries because of this grand plan
that um, they want to achieve. And I
think you're absolutely right. Part of
this grand plan is to create the
antichrist. Um,
I mean like
people say this online and it's it's the
weirdest thing, but Peter the anagram of
his name is the reptile and that's like
the strange coincidence. Um but but you
know I mean like again I mean I I don't
want to go too deep into this but if you
look at the history of the secret
societies in America in Britain they do
plan ahead and what they often do is
they raise children from
>> birth from the cradle to achieve certain
roles in the biblical prophecy. I mean
like they they are that organized they
are that that evil. They will actually
take children and um and and basically
nurture that child in order to achieve a
certain role that they need that they
need to um that they need in order to
fulfill the script. And I mean like if
you just look at the world around the
world today and you ask yourself who is
most likely to be the antichrist.
>> Um I mean it's Peter Teal. I mean I mean
I hate to say this but
>> I mean he has all the markings of the
the antichrist. I mean he wants to
create a surveillance state through
palent terror. Um he he wants he wants
um a return to theocracy, a world
government. I I mean I mean you have to
ask yourself what drives this guy um
>> to overcome the human condition. I mean
he he as he said I mean that that's what
he meant by should humanity survive. I I
don't think he wants us all to, you
know, die off from starvation or war or
something. I think I think he wants to
overcome the human condition by merging
with machines that, you know, we we
became cyborgs when we had artificial
hearts and and limbs and we're now
connected with computers with our in our
through our hand the phone and and this
is just the beginning of overcoming the
mortal coil coil. I think that's exactly
how he thinks. So it's a it's a weird
com, you know, and he he compared it
where it it was very funny because that
type of thinking, you know,
technofuturism, the singularity,
posthumanism, etc. You associate that
with extreme liberals perhaps or
atheist, no doubt, people who, you know,
h don't care for gods and church and all
that kind of stuff. It's the opposite
with Peter Tal. He he seems to be he
called himself orthodox in that
interview. He seems to he has this
interpretation or kind of skew of the
Christian message where with
Christianity we sort of perfect our soul
and we're not bogged down by uh
quotidian things. We're we're kind of
moving towards God. And he sees that as
a metaphor or or analogy of moving
towards the perfection of the machine of
pure logic of artificial intelligence of
living forever uh etc etc. So, in some
ways, Peter Teal is the ultimate
Christian. I mean, or anti-Christian,
you know, I I, you know, so to speak.
He's he's offering this sort of he's not
countering Christianity or saying it's
all bunk and superstition and lies. He's
in say instead saying, "No, no, this is
the real Christianity. This is what God
has in store for you, merging with the
machine."
>> Yeah. I mean, I completely agree. I I
mean I mean so so so I'll just go over
some of his bio biographic details
>> and like I mean he was a chess prodigy.
I mean he I mean like like he was
fantastic of chess. He went to Stanford
where he became where he was mentored by
Renee Gerard.
>> Um you know this very influential French
philosopher who was very close with the
Catholic Church. I mean I mean I I would
be surprised if if he has a Jesuit
background if he was part of these
secret societies of the Jesuits. um went
to Stanford Law School and then he
joined PayPal.
>> Now the PayPal mafia I mean I mean like
like I don't think enough people have
focused on the PayPal mafia because
>> just go back to founding of the internet
and any anyone could tell you at that
time like whoever controlled um e
payments whoever can control commerce on
the internet these people would
eventually come to control the internet.
So my question then is how did Peter
Teal get associated with these people
and how did they become one of the top
players in these people along with Ella
Mus and David Saxs. I mean I mean like
like it seems almost as though they were
secret society onto themselves and that
people in power put them there to
achieve certain purposes. Um but I I
mean he was extremely he was either
extremely lucky or it was planned from
the beginning and after um you know
PayPal he he was an early investor in
Facebook and he found a talenteer with
his college roommate Alex Karp and and
and now he's I he was an early support
of Donald Trump. He's now he he was an
early support of JD Vance. Um you can
argue like JD Vance career would not
have been possible without Peter Theo.
So I mean I this guy I I this guy is the
most brunt man in the world and you
actually listen to his interviews if you
actually read his writings it doesn't he
doesn't come across as the most br in
the world or
powerful factions are supporting him and
he's the front man for these powerful
factions which which I think is the most
um likely scenario and then you ask
yourself what's his plan from birth who
who who is his family I mean we have we
know very little about his family and
like like what why is this happening? Um
why why does he believe what he does?
Because he he's unique in that Silicon
Silicon Valley ecosystem. You look some
like Jeff Bezos. I mean like he's a very
typical Silicon Valley Silicon Valley
billionaire, right? I mean like he
>> I mean divorce he's he's trying to shoot
rockets into space like a fall symbol.
So, so you're going to sort of see like
his like like like you know he he's
trying to he's trying to satis satisfize
his own ego, his own limitations whereas
Peter Teal clearly he's a man on a
mission. I mean like and he's written
quite quite a lot about the convergence
of the theology and um artificial
intelligence right transhumanism as you
call it. So, so, so it's almost like
they have a plan in motion and Peter
Teal is just a puppet put in front of us
in order to seduce us into this plan.
It's very hard um to explain how he got
to where he is and why he believes what
he does. I mean, he he's unique that's
ecosystem.
>> Yeah, I I agree. It's very interesting
because he he was almost a about
politics before he was about technology
and exactly you know it when he was an
undergrad he actually wrote a book you
know I think it was called the diversity
myth which was uh pretty standard
anti-dei
kind of stuff. Uh but you know
interesting that he was doing that. He
actually worked with um William Bennett
for a time uh before PayPal actually. So
he was already involved with
neoonservative politics before he became
a billionaire. It was it was almost like
he had the ideas ready to go and he was
well connected but the one thing he was
missing was a billion dollars. So we had
to do a little detour and um yeah even
even the whole PayPal bringing on Musk
and and and so on there there there is
something haphazard about it and I I
don't want to be resentful or try to
take anything away from them but when
you look at the company particularly
Musk um contributions to PayPal it it it
does seem
dubious to be honest or at the very
least lucky.
Um, and it is interesting that both of
these figures were chosen, if we're to
assume that the the sort of theological
Peter Teal and and then also Elon Musk
who is is constantly wanting to save the
world. Um, you know, when he was a
Reddit liberal, he was talking about
how, you know, there's a 40% chance that
uh we can save off global warming now
that we have electric vehicles and so
on. Then he sort of moves off that and
you know we we need to desperately elect
Donald Trump in order to save America
and save free speech that they want to
kill you now is what he's saying. So he
they they both sort of have they're
they're different figures but they they
both sort of have messianic callings
>> and and it is interesting to compare
them to just sort of a dude like Jeff
Bezos who's just a good businessman and
you know loves hanging out with chicks.
uh much more understandable than these
other figures um who are sort of asexual
both of them in in different weird ways.
Um
but okay, let me um let me change the So
do you want to tie up any bows on the
Middle East uh situation in in the terms
of the immediate future or uh uh you you
actually have a lecture on World War II
and and how you know the Middle East,
China, even certainly the conflict in
Europe over Ukraine, how these
>> pieces might fit together.
>> Yeah. I mean, um I think World War II
will mainly center in the Levant and
Anatolia. Um that's part of all the
esquetology, the biblical prophecy. Um
and so I I see certain events playing
out. I I see um the Israelis
um basically continuing to do what what
what they do in Gaza, but but a much
more accelerated pace. Um I see the
Israelis or or I actually I'm not going
to say the Israelis but but the I'll
accept Mos will be blown up. Who? Why?
We we won't know but it'll be blown up.
It was shock to the world which is the
intention.
>> Um I see um a continuation of the
conflict between Israel and Iran. Um I
see the United States sending in ground
troops uh against um Iran. Iran will
close off the street of humus which will
um just create economic um an economic
catastrophe all around the world. It's
going to severely impact the the
Southeast Asian economies of China, uh
Japan and South Korea. I mean it's I
mean it's it's going to be a mess and
but again it's all part of the plan.
It's all part part of the script in
order to achieve the meditating age. Um
and um so so I I think that's that's
what's what's going to happen in the
Middle East.
>> Is this going to be the downfall of the
United States in this war? Because I
mean we we benefited tremendously from
the two world wars in the 20th century.
And we joined both late. We joined both
arguably reluctantly. Um and uh we were
on it was clear which side we were going
to join though and we were supporting
them. But um America is a very different
country now. It's hard to imagine
zoomers strapping on helmets and going
off to Iran to go to war. It's it's hard
to imagine both the left and the right
even acting as good soldiers on the home
front in a conflict. I I I wonder if the
next big one is the last one for Uncle
Sam.
>> That's the intention actually. Um so the
estology requires um Israel to achieve
the greater Israel project u basically
the past Judea for for Israel the
dominant power in the Middle East. And
so you need to get rid of the United
States somehow, right? You need to
remove the United States from the
equation because the United States
doesn't figure into um the esqueology.
And the best way to do that
>> is to provoke an American grand invasion
of Iran because that thing will be so
unpopular as to ignite a civil war in
the United States which will which will
destabilize United States and prevent
the United States from u interfering in
Middle East affairs. Right? that that I
think is part of the esquetology because
if you look at all the esquetologies
whether it's Orthodox, Catholic, um,
Jewish or Christian, you look at all the
escology, United States will descend
into civil war. That's what they all
believe. That's what they all say. So,
and that's important for what's about to
unfold in the Middle East because United
States is the Pax Americanana. It's it's
going to prevent the war from spiring
out of control, but you need the war to
spire out of control in order to create
the conditions for the military age. So
you need to remove the United States
from the equation. The best way to do
that is for the United States to suffer
a humane defeat in Iran and then this
this will provoke civil conflict in
America. And now America is not is no
longer part of the equation.
>> Israel is in a golden cage with the
United States. We give Israel billions.
At the same time the American empire
constrains Israel. That's
>> exactly right.
>> You know certainly I mean even Donald
Trump constrains Bivby Netanyahu. Uh
surely uh uh Kla Harris would have uh
pushed back on his actions more much
more than Trump if she were elected and
any Democrat would and and many other
Republicans would. So it's a sort of
golden cage. It's been wonderful for
quite some time. They benefited from it,
but everything has to come to an end. Um
so let's talk about the end of my
country where I'm living right now.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, first off, so what was it
like? So you you moved to Canada to
Toronto when you were six, you said. So
you don't I I guess it would be hard to
remember a whole lot about China before
you you immigrated. Maybe you have
flashes,
>> postcard images of of what China was
like. What What was it
what was it like to be a a Chinese
immigrant kid in in Canada? Like were
you did you feel like you were in
paradise or did you maybe feel like you
were an outsider or you know sort of
both?
>> Well I mean so I mean um my family was
very poor
>> and so we lived in poor neighborhoods
where um there was these mixing mixing
of the different ethnicities but
obviously these are not really educated
people. they're not cosmopolitan. And so
I suffered a lot of uh racial abuse when
I was younger. Um and and that's what
sort of compelled me to want to leave
Canada and apply to United States
because I wanted to just get out of
Canada was it's such a traumatic um
experience. Um but quite honestly
sometimes when I go back to Canada I
still find it um traumatic because it
will stir stir up these childhood
memories of racial abuse and and and all
that but but you know I mean like at the
same time I'm very thankful um uh for
for Canada because you know grow up in
the 80s and 90s was really the best time
to be alive. Um nowadays you're a young
person in Canada it kind of sucks. um
the the country society has changed a
lot. But
>> in the 80s, in the 90s when I grew up,
you were allow you were allowed a lot of
personal freedom. You could go out and
explore the streets. You could you could
take risks. You could fail. It was not a
big deal. It was all part of the process
of growing up growing up. You know, I
took my two kids uh two boys back to
Canada over the summer. And like you
know nowadays they expect you as a
parent to have your child on a leash
like literally a leash you know to to
like like like make sure the child is
always always within arms reach
>> and and I was like but but but if I did
that then how my how will my child ever
learn resilience? How how my child ever
learn empathy, independence,
>> uh you know risk takingaking,
creativity, imagination like like and
and and so I I was very fortunate to
have grown up in the 80s rather than
than than today. So, I'm thankful
thankful for for what Canada provided.
At the same time, um I I did suffer a
lot of racial abuse while grow up in
Canada.
>> I I I understand that completely.
Growing up in the late 80s and early
90s, and I I I was born in
Massachusetts, but I I moved to uh
Texas. And we would ride during the
summer, we would ride our bikes from
9:00 a.m. until 9:00 p.m. And maybe stop
go to mom for lunch and something like
that. But yeah, we would, you know, play
a baseball game, play a football game,
go on an adventure, someone would get
his knee skinned and and hurt and so on.
But it, you know, again, I I I don't
want to stereotype here, but it does
seem like the Zoomers are trapped on
their computer, their phone, or their
video game console, and this
overprotective cocoon they live in where
they barely leave their home. Um, yeah,
it makes me absolut I totally agree.
just out of curiosity. Oh, well, go on
if you want to. Yeah.
>> No, but but but also like the drug the
prevalence of drugs right now among
children like like like if you move in
class, okay, because you're bored
because the the teacher's boring, you
move a bit. Oh, you have ADHD, so you
should take or whatever. And like like
like that's a first option. It's never
like maybe the teacher is boring and the
kid is bored and maybe he's a boy, so he
likes to move about and
>> yeah, maybe should go outside. Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's not natural for a kid to sit
inside for eight, nine hours a day. U
they need to be outside because that's
that's why we have bodies, right? I
mean, like, you know, if you know, and
and and and and so it's it's it's just I
mean, it's it's just crazy the society
that that that the West has become. I
mean, these past 10 years.
I I don't want to bring up bad feelings
or anything, but you said you suffered a
lot of racial abuse as a as an outsider
in Canada. I I don't doubt it. What was
that actually coming from white
Canadians or was that you said you also
grew in a mixed neighborhood? What what
was the dynamic there?
>> Yeah. I mean, so um you know, there were
different factors going on. So um I was
poor so you know my father cut my hair
like like I like I wore like you know
cheap clothes and so and I really
couldn't engage in the kids in the
conversations they want to have which
like they they love playing Sega
Nintendo we we couldn't afford a
Nintendo and Sega
>> um so so there were a lot of different
factors go going on but um and and I I
also had like a weird personality I'm
just a weird person uh you know I'm
hyperactive I'm sensitive. Um, so but
but yeah, I mean, um, like it was a mix
a mix of of ethnicities. I I primarily
grew up in a Greek neighborhood. Uh, and
these were also immigrants. Um, but but
you know, I mean like I I mean it's just
natural for kids identify the outsider
and to think of the outsider, you're not
welcome. So, you know, I mean, I I I was
I was hit I was hit at I mean like like
the kids would would punch me and stuff,
but also like they wouldn't let me play
their games. I was never invited to
their parties. I was shunned and
ostracized and verbally and physically
abused. Yes.
>> Yeah. But it gives you a a perspective
on things that maybe you wouldn't have
if you're in it. So there there's there
are there are benefits to um to these
things. But let let's talk about America
and the Civil War. So obviously we've
had one of these before in the 1860s and
it led to hundreds of thousands of
deaths. Listening to your lecture on the
the coming civil war I I the 1860s is a
precedent but I don't I you seem to not
think that something like that is going
to happen that that was a regional
conflict over slavery and secession. I
mean it was a war of secession in many
ways. I I think the South did want to uh
break away uh and and the North wanted
to maintain this empire.
>> Um but what do you think the upcoming
civil war is going to be like? Because
we you know the the idea of a civil war
is sort of in the air. Marjorie Taylor
Green has said we need a divorce, a
national divorce, a kind of velvet
divorce. We'll just agree to disagree.
But how exactly that would shake out
remains to be seen. red state, blue
state. They're they're fairly
consistent, but there's a lot of, you
know, Illinois is a massive dot of blue.
Chicago in a red state, for example.
>> Um I I live in Montana now. I I know
exactly how Montana would go.
>> Very deep red out here with with the um
not not a lot of blue anywhere. Uh but
uh but but also there's there's also the
idea of you know imagine yourself as the
president and as presiding over the
American empire. We obviously benefit at
the end of the day despite the problems
from remaining intact. A civil war is
going to bring down the dollar as a
reserve currency. It's going to
jeopardize overseas bases. It's going to
obviously jeopardize prestige maybe
indelibly and I would imag if I were
president I probably wouldn't let
Montana go if it wanted to do so
peacefully. You're you're in a kind of
damned if you do damned if you don't
dilemma but maybe that you should take
the Lincoln option. So So anyway, I've
set up this I put out some ideas. How do
you think this is going to shake out? A
and then and then B I I want you to talk
also about the sort of like deeper
currents you see of what what's really
causing this. But but first we'll we'll
stick with the pragmatic. How how do you
think this might shake out?
>> Okay. So um I think it will not be a war
um as you say like in that there'll be
two sides. You have two armies and they
fight each other because um you know I
mean like that's that's not what's going
to happen. But what we will see is um in
the first well I I think the civil war
might last 20 20 30 years um and and I
think what will emerge at the end of the
civil war is a Christian theocracy where
the United States embraces Christian
nationalism as a defining ideology u and
that Christian Zionism uh sorry
Christian nationalism sort of like
overrides the constitution. Okay that's
that that that's what I think will be
the most likely scenario in 20 30 years
time.
>> Wow. Wow. And to get to that point, you
have different stages. Okay. In the
first stage, you have see you'll see an
acceleration of political violence, you
know, so public figures are targeted. Um
you'll see massive public unrest. So
going back to the LA riots, right, the
against um ICE raids, right? Um you will
see an acceleration of the police state
um you know the National Guard in
different cities. Um
then the first stage I think ends when
there's a defining political moment that
radically transforms political landscape
of this country and I think that will be
Trump's third term. I think Trump
intends to continue to be president. How
he will do so I don't know right? I mean
it's possible he runs his son Don Jr.
and he's the vice president. Who knows?
Okay. But I think his intention is to
have a third term. And I think like from
all his actions, you can interpret it as
he wants to stay in there for as long as
he can, right? Um it's possible dies out
of office, but but I think, you know, if
if he stays healthy, then he's going to
want that third term. If if he does that
and he succeeds, I think he will likely
succeed because he'll cheat in 2028.
Um you will have massive revolt in the
country. You have you have cities like
New York, Boston who are open who are
open defiance. um some states like
California, they might even choose to
succeed from the union and now you're
going to have a massive um conflict
throughout the nation. Most of the
country will actually not be affected if
you know if you're just living in a
suburb Connecticut, this may not even
affect you. But if you're living in a
city of New York City or Boston, um you
have these massive sieges. Okay. Um then
as in the third stage then I think
you'll have like just a breakdown of the
United States you know and uh different
states will will fight against each
other. Different states will fight fight
fight against each other but eventually
I think um the red states like Texas
maybe um they will become dominant and
they will then and they will eventually
re reunite re reform the United States
of America. Um and honestly this is no
different from what happened um during
Roman times during the Roman Empire. I
mean you you had a constant process of
civil war and u a great leader emerges
and then you have imperial constant
consolidation and then like maybe 20
years 30 years later civil war again. So
it's it's a constant cycle and I I quite
honestly I I think that's going to
what's going to happen in the United
States. At the same time, and this is
what's really interesting, is even as
this civil war gets worse and worse,
America will continue to expand in the
Americas. Uh, America's going to claim
territory in Canada, in Mexico, in South
America. Um, so I I think that is what I
imagine to be to happen over the next 20
30 years to America. Um and again this
fits into the esquetology because
America needs to be isolated from the
rest of the world because the rest of
the world needs to achieve the second
coming and and so the civil war this
impermanent expansion throughout the
Americas uh it will distract America
long enough for the events to unfold in
the Middle East in the way that they
should. Um so yeah
>> and so you think
>> well go ahead finish your thoughts.
>> Yeah. And and also I I think like one of
the hidden hands in all the civil war
will be the Catholic Church. I I I I I
think the Catholic Church is a much more
dominant player um underlying American
politics than people imagine it to to
play. I mean like like look I mean JD
Vance um I mean like he is he will be
regardless of what happens I mean he
will be a very dominant political player
in the next few decades and he's a very
young person right
>> the new pope of the Catholic church is
American so so I I would not I I would
not be surprised if there are certain
institutional elements within the
Catholic church maybe maybe Opus die sty
the Jesuits who see the civil wars
opportunity to gain power in um America
Because remember before the
Anglo-American Empire, it was a Catholic
empire. And so how do you reconstitute
the millennium? How do we rec
reconstitute the Catholic empire? Well,
you either bring America into the fold.
Uh you call up America or you you you
cause America to disintegrate, right? So
yeah. So so I I think the Catholic
Church will walls play a very important
role in in in in the coming decades.
>> And so you see the Civil War as left
versus right in effect. I mean the the
first Civil War was regional. you you
couldn't well there was a little bit of
slavery in Massachusetts but you you
couldn't have a massive gone with the
wind style plantation in Connecticut or
or something like that. There was
regional differences of geography that
created different economies that were
interconnected of course but were were
different and this led to a regional
conflict but it wasn't left versus right
exactly. You you had different types of
people on both sides, but you you think
that the red state, blue state divide,
left versus right versus left in this
case, that is going to be it. And and
we're we're a hyper polarized society.
This is how we think now. Everything's
coded as Republican and Democrat. If
we're going to break down, those are
going to be the fault lines.
Um um I think on a surface that's a
fault line but I don't think that that's
what what happened. I think the larger
conflict is between establishment
interests versus emerging elite
interests. Right? So the example is
Donald Trump,
>> right? So um in 2020 the establishment
elite coales together to get rid of
Donald Trump,
>> right? I mean like $6 billion dollars
were spent on an election. the entire
elite apparatus, the media, the
financial sector, um the deep state,
CIA, uh they all banned together to get
rid of Donald Trump. And what and and
back back to the Peter Teal, remember
what was interesting is 2016, 2024,
Peter Teal was a vocal supporter of
Donald Trump, but in 2020, he withdrew
his support for Donald Trump. So it
seemed like like at that time the entire
establishment got together and decided
we need to get rid of this guy because
he's a liability to imperial interest
and then you know Joe Biden came in and
they recognized that Joe Lines is
actually even worse for for imperial
interest and that's why they let Donald
Trump to come back in but obviously if
you're Donald Trump you're kind of
pissed off about what happened 2020. Um
I mean so so I I think you know project
uh the law the underlying hidden agenda
of project 2025 is to start attacking
the basic infrastructure of
establishment and I I I think I think
that is what's really driving the civil
war these elites come you know Peter
Turin the historian has a term for this
elite over production you have limited
position of power status you have too
many elites they all want these position
of power so they're going have to uh
fight it amongst themselves. So, so I
think left right is what we see but
behind it are these deep institutional
elements these interests that are in
conflict with each other and left right
are basically puppets or tools. I mean
you can make argument and tea and tifa I
mean it's I mean it's not an organic
organization. I mean like it's it's
almost like like a FBI undercover
organization. Um and then on the right
you have um Patriot Front or or or
whatever they call it. But it's so
blatant. I mean what what they're doing
now. Now why would you do that? Why you
why would you incubate these
organizations? Well I mean you would
incubate these organizations if you want
to activate them for a um for civil
civil unrest. Um so I think in the first
stage it will be establishment versus
um these these the these um um Trump
aligned conservative factions that are
trying to overthrow the establishment
including Chrisinist including the
Mormons including the Catholics. Okay.
But eventually you reach a point where
the is overthrown and now these factions
fight amongst themselves. Um so
>> but but I think what's really important
for us to understand is the left is not
a factor in the civil war. The left is
extremely disorganized. I mean these
past few decades um the left has done a
tremendous job in um consuming itself in
destroying itself through wake uh
through woke ideology through its
alignment with the establishment through
its it it's its um through co lockdowns.
I mean like the left has just absolutely
no credibility
>> in America nowadays.
>> It just doesn't I mean like like and
like quite honestly the left they're not
going to die for what they believe
because they don't believe anything. You
look like people like Obama, AOC, right?
Do they stand for anything? I I don't
think they stand for anything. All All
they stand for really is, you know, like
playing the game, moving up. But but
Obama's not not going to die for for
what he believes in, whereas people on
the right will die for what what for
what they believe in. And and and I so I
don't think the left is a factor in the
civil war.
>> Yeah. Well, there there's also something
that I've noticed is that the first nine
months or so of the Trump second term,
uh, it's it's been this attack on the
establishment,
>> but without replacing it with anything.
You know,
>> Elon Musk came out with a chainsaw and
said, you know, we're destroying
bureaucracy. Now, I don't I don't think
he really destroyed all that much, but
it was an attack on USAD. It was attack
on long-term bureaucrats, etc. Even
something as trivial as getting Jimmy
Kimmel fired. I don't know if you heard
this. Uh he's this very boring and
stupid talk um a late night talk show.
Well, previously in American history,
uh, late night was actually a very
unifying thing. Johnny Carson spoke to
all Americans, middle class, the the
wealthy elite, even uh, workingclass
people. They all liked Johnny Carson.
And they thought the celebrities he
talked to were were their friends. And
Bob Uker would come on and talk about
baseball. It it was very unifying and
homey. And Jimmy Kimmel is nothing like
that. He's polarized himself and he's
he's boring. But even here, you have an
attack on the institution. This thing is
falling. Let's just push it over the
edge. But at least from my standpoint,
there's nothing.
There's no institution that's replacing
it. You know, there there's not there
there's not a Trump USAID or there
there's not like a new vision of
government that's replacing what they're
tearing down. There's not a Trump late
night host who brings everyone together.
They're they're in the stage of
liquidating all of these institutions
that are actually 20th century
institutions. They're quite old, but
they've all been coded liberal. Attack
the universities. Let's bring Harvard is
going to be neutered. They're going to
pay us money. We might even take them
down. They're they're getting rid of
these things, but they're they're not
presenting hegemonic institutions in
their place. At least that's my
perception. So, you know, I guess what
what you're saying is that
at the end of it, it's going to be
Christian nationalism. It's just it's
going to be just full-on
uh, you know, it's in the Bible. Ten
Commandments, baby. Uh, bake me the
cake, convert the gays. I mean, um, I
guess it makes sense in the sense that I
don't think Trumpism has any core belief
other than Trump himself and he is going
to die at some point, maybe soon. And
something has to fill that void. There's
no other personality that can fill it.
Maybe you some sort of hardcore thing,
but something that resonates with
American history. And and to be frank,
Puritanism,
uh, biblical fundamentalism, that
resonates with American history from my
perspective,
>> unfortunately. But you have to find
something to to to fill that void.
>> Yeah. So I mean what I will say is that
um if you're a Christian Zionist you
believe like the media the judiciary and
the universities are fundamentally
liberal institutions and therefore you
have to burn out these institutions if
you are to spread your Christian
nationalist ideology when you have the
ideology in place and these institutions
will come about that support the
ideology so um I don't think the
intention is is to replace the
universities I think the intention is is
just to burn them down because like why
do you need that? Why do you need need
universities? They're just propaganda
machines for the liberal elite. I mean,
>> why
sadly? Yes.
>> Yeah. Like, why? Just burn them down.
Like, like like who needs them, right?
>> I Yeah. That's why I'm I'm just speaking
for myself. I am about a lot of this
because I I don't like the
destructiveness and I feel like so much
of the destructiveness is very stupid.
It's it's people who resent the idea of
Harvard. You know, I I think that the
idea of people gather 20 people
gathering at a table and discussing
Milton is a great thing and and a
necessary thing for building the elite.
And I feel like there is a sort of
stupid resentment against the idea of
education itself. That being said, it's
very hard for me to defend Jimmy Kimmel
or defend Harvard as it is at at this
moment. I sort of reluctantly agree with
the Trump movement that these
institutions have gone haywire. So
>> look, I mean, look, it's these liberal
institutions that created Trump. Okay? I
mean, like, it's very important we
understand this. Trump is not a
self-creation. He is a creation of the
liberal institutions that hate him.
Okay. So in 2016 um you know Trump
became popular because he was he was he
was being anti-Obama. I mean he he was
he was going to he was he was this
populist u hero right? Why? Because the
Obama years created this tremendous
inequality between the the halves and
the have nots. And um I mean people were
just sick sick of this. Remember in 20
2008, Obama came in promising that he
would clean up Wall Street. And all he
did was bail out Wall Street and punish
these millions of homeowners who lost
their homes because of Wall Street
shenanigans because of Wall Street
corruption
>> and and Trump promised that I will fix
this. Okay.
>> When he came into office, he was
sabotaged from day one by the liberal
elite, right? the media was spreading
this Russian hoax that you know that
that that Trump was was a Putin spy. Um
and and you had you had the um you had
certain individuals in Trump's cabinet
that were in open rebellion against
Trump who refused to take Trump's
orders. In fact, you had the chairman of
the joint chief of staff, Mark Millie,
um say very proudly, I called the
Chinese and said, "Don't worry about
this guy. We're not take orders from
this guy. He's a loose cannon. Don't
worry about it." Okay, that's that's
true. You don't do that. Okay, that
that's that basically treason. But he
said it with relish. Okay, the entire
media establishment went against Trump.
And then in 2020, as I mentioned, the
entire establishment spent $6 million to
get to get rid rid of this guy. All
right. And that should have been it. But
then you had January 6, which was I mean
arguably a federal operation. But then
after that, you had the liberals um try
to bankrupt Trump. I mean, there were
six civil suits against Trump. they were
trying to form in prison. You have these
judges in Colorado who are who are
trying to take him out like like like
out of the the ballot. You have this
raid on Marilago for who knows why, but
the FBI rated him. So So I mean I mean
the media, the liberals were obsessed
with this guy and because Trump was
being persecuted by the uh liberal
elite, the institutional elite, he made
it made him a folk hero in America.
Americans don't like that when the
government bullies someone. I mean I
mean it it goes it goes against the very
soul of America to be bullied by the
government like that when Trump was
being bullied throughout throughout
throughout all this time. And so you
have this former president who is a
billionaire and now he's like a folk
hero. He's the underdog and now that he
swore back into office he has a popular
mandate to to bulldo like all these
institutions that bullied him um past
eight years. So, I'm sorry to say this,
but these liberal students did this to
themselves. At no point did was there
any self-reflection. At no point did
anyone say, "You know what? Um, we're
going too far."
>> Um, we say we we're we say we're calling
him Hitler, but are we creating Hitler?
Like, yeah, like remember because Hitler
would not be have been Hitler without
the popular mandate that he had because
because of the all these like decades of
frustration among the German people.
>> Yes, I I agree with um uh so much of
what you've said, but he's like a
wrecking ball. I mean, it it's it's
fascinating.
>> That's the intention. So, it but so it's
it's a force higher than these liberal
institutions. It's it's not like the
dean of a Harvard college is is truly
like the elite in the sense of the the
man, you know, calling the shots. And so
I I think there there were so many
things with Trump as you said when he it
was perceived that he was being
persecuted by Jack Smith. That's when he
became popular again and they threw
Ronda Santis out the window. Um, also
January 6, you saw all of these
billionaires, maybe they're sort of
former liberal billionaires,
counterbillionaires, you could say, who
came on side because Joe Biden and Kla
Harris, even if they ultimately support
Israel, they are more likely to push
back. And I do think that there was a
certain elite that wanted Trump despite
all of it. They thought that he was
going to be the one for that that would
allow Israel to pursue its dreams in the
most expansive way popular uh possible,
excuse me. And and thus Trump isn't this
counter elite. He isn't the anti-war
president. He's he's actually brought in
by certain elites that
>> uh want this. And yeah, in in terms of
what he creates, it's not even
necessarily his fault, uh, just to be
fair, but in terms of what he creates,
the vibe that he brings to the country,
there's no doubt
the the Charlie Kirk assassination as an
example, we do seem to be getting closer
to street level kinetic violence day by
day. I don't I don't think you think
this. I don't think any reasonable
person thinks that we're not going to
see another one of these things like
Charlie Kirk, someone who is deeply
politically coded and symbolic
getting killed, getting uh uh roughed up
at the very least, being a violently
attacked in broad daylight for the
simple reason of sending a message. and
and and the message the violence there
becoming so much more expansive on
social media. Millions of people are
seeing it and feeling it right then and
there. And thus Trump sort of brings in
the civil war. Maybe to to be overly
fair here. Maybe not well, you know, I
think he did urge people to do J6 and
whatever, but to be fair, overly fair.
Not really to the fault of his own, but
just the sort of energy that he brings
to the table. He brings an energy of
violence. I think a lot of liberals have
gotten in trouble for saying this, but I
I think they're they're actually right
about that. Um, and it we're not going
to cool things down. We're not going to
go back to normal. We're not going to
elect Mitt Romney or something like that
where we can just sort of tune out of
politics, you know, maybe make fun of
the president here and there. Um, wi
with Trump, the the general social mood
of the country is more existential.
I think with this Charlie Cook uh
shooting uh America has another 911
moment. Um I I think I think it's a
watershed mo moment and I and I think
you're absolutely right in that there's
no going back after this. um it it's
opened a Pandora door's box
>> and remember after 911 um two major
things that happened were the Patriot
Act um the beginning of the surveillance
state and then the these wars in the
Middle East and and I and I I think that
with this Charlie Cook Charlie Cook
shooting
>> you have both. Yeah, you have both. I
mean you're going to have Palunteer
become dominant. Um I mean they've been
planning this for like a long long time,
right? that the infrastructure u for all
this I'm sure there there are lots of
legislation already you know written
that they're going to put the ramp
through over next few few months in so
in to in like you know in memory of of
Charlie Kirk okay to to celebrate his
his memory right they they'll probably
call the Charlie Kirk act or whatever
you know the patriarch patriarch act 2
or something and I I also think this
will be the impetus for America's
invasion of Iran somehow somehow they're
they're going to connect the two And you
know because like after 911 they invaded
Iraq and like there was actually no
connection between 911 and Iraq. In fact
Iraq was a enemy of al-Qaeda but they
invaded Iraq anyway. So so so I think
this is a watershed moment and I I don't
think you can
>> um overestimate the impact on the
American psyche of of what happened.
>> They're already doing military
recruitment on Charlie Kirk's behalf.
Charlie Kirk never served in the
military. I mean, you know, for what
it's worth.
>> And Charlie Kirk, by the way, was the
one who vocally told Trump not to bomb
Iran.
>> He told Trump, "We have actually no
business bombing Iran." Um, the American
people don't want a war in the Middle
East. I mean, Charlie Charlie Cook Kirk
was one of one of the good guys in
Trump's orbit. I mean, he was one of the
resting forces, right?
>> Sure, I'll I'll grant you that. But I do
agree that he no doubt went and told
Donald Trump that because he was getting
pressure from his sort of anti-war base.
And the the the the the amazing thing,
but maybe even predictive thing is that
they're going to use him to inspire a
war. What one thing that I've also
noticed here is that
>> I I think so many liberals want the
establishment to push back. They the the
media does push back to some degree uh
to the degree they can but they almost
want you know these governors to stand
up to Trump and they have to some
Pritsker and Newsome to some degree.
>> Uh but they they they're almost waiting
for some establishmentarian
wasp and a tweed coat to just come out
of the woodwork and say no we don't do
that here. And I I think what what I've
seen in in in Donald Trump's second term
is that that doesn't actually exist. You
know, they are going to send the
National Guard into California. Um Tim
Cook, Mr. Liberal Apple, you know,
leftcoded company. Uh what are they
going to do? They're going to come to
the White House and kiss Trump's ass. Um
the the mainstream media, are they going
to push back on behalf of free speech
and democracy? No. They're actually
going to fire the people whom Trump
hates. There's nothing coming from the
so-called establishment because that's
not really the establishment. the these
institution long-standing institutions,
you know, the New York Times, ABC,
Harvard University, um uh all these
these are 20th century institutions that
have now been coded as liberal and
people want them to push back. Uh but
they just won't and they can't because
they're not an actual elite. They're a
sort of like sub elite of something else
that might actually like what Donald
Trump is doing.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. I mean, the liberal
elite is the professional managerial
class, right? They're not the owners.
>> They're not they're not the bosses. It's
the deep state, the uh um that that that
are the bosses and we'll never know who
they are. Uh one point one thing I will
say is remember during the Trump first
term, the liberal elite basically sold
their soul to the deep state, right?
because um rather than reflect on what
they did wrong that would that would
allow for uh the election of Donald
Trump rather than recognize their own
limitations and commit to certain
changes in their behavior. They decided
that you know what we'll we'll get the
deep state to go after Trump and and and
create a soft court, right? Robert
Müller in his report will definitely
indict Trump, right? The joint chief of
staff will will overthrow Trump or
whatever. Okay? But but basically the
liberally sold their soul to the deep
state. And now and then after the deep
state realized, you know, we're better
off with Donald Trump because we need to
create wars in the Middle East to in
order to uh expand the military
industrial complex. Now they're
liberally just kind of stuck because as
you say, they don't they don't have any
real power and they they've sold their
soul. at least a long time ago.
>> Yes. Yeah. Absolutely. Um well, let's do
this. We we have about um 20 more
minutes to to go or so. And you've been
very generous with your time and I've
really been, you know, um invigorated by
this discussion. But let let me open it
up to some uh questions um which uh you
could entertain if you're if you're
willing.
>> Okay. Sure.
>> Yeah. Uh, Ateas, uh, you're up there
first. Go for it.
>> Uh, yeah. Um, I I had a question about
the, it was briefly talked about, which
is the idea that, you know, Johnny
Carson being, you know, a very unifying
figure or figure and how everything is
kind of self-curated. So, like if you
want news, you kind of you go on the
internet and you get news for yourself.
Um, I guess my question would be like
what do you how much of it do you
attribute to this kind of theory of a
civil war of this idea that nothing is
unifying anymore? Um, I think the only
last thing that's unifying really is
probably sports, but I don't really
think that's kind of powerful.
>> Yeah, I I mean that that's exactly
right. um you have a breakdown over the
past 20 years of three things that were
unifying. Um ideology, narrative,
stories, and institutions, right? Um so
Johnny Carson was an institution in
America. Television was an institution
in America because everyone just sat
down as a family and watched TV
together. That that's what you did in
the 60s and and 50s and and 70s. So um
all these unifying forces uh especially
ideology like what what's America stand
for? What is America about? Uh like like
what is the American dream? I mean it's
it's died out. I mean like like it's
it's been ruptured and again there's
really no going back to to it. The only
only unifying ideology on the horizon
that I see is Christian nationalism to
return to America's roots as the new
Jerusalem um as a city on the hill. Um
that's that's about it. Um and and and I
think that's that's why you're seeing
what um you're seeing. I mean, the fact
that um after the assassination of
Charlie Kirk, you had a lot of people
celebrate his death is a really bad omen
for America. It just tells us that
there's no shame. There's no guilt.
There there's no sense of civility in
America anymore. Um it it I mean like
like we we've all been uh primed by
social media to behave with outrage, to
behave with extreme emotion, and there's
really no space for self-reflection, for
restraint, for civility uh anymore in
America.
>> Yes.
>> I think the Can I Sorry.
>> Yeah, sure. You can follow.
>> I was just going to add one more thing.
It does seem like um you know whoever
has the strongest channel of information
which would be like the theocracy of the
Catholic Church or something you know if
you have like the most unifying channel
for a message you would then become the
establishment of messaging people. So
you know you know I guess I'm just
reinforcing and agreeing with what
you're saying.
Yeah, I I again I would not um
underestimate the power and the reach of
the Catholic Church. I mean they have a
hierarchy. Um they they're extremely
well organized and they've been lying
their weight for hundred hundreds of
years, right? I mean like there's just
there's this um for hundreds of years
there's been this secret war between the
Jesuits and the Freemasons. Um and this
war has spilled over to um America and
this war has never gone gone away. So,
um, so, so, yeah, I mean, like, watch
out for the Catholic Church. In fact,
you know, I mean, like look at Kenneth
Owens, um, and just look at what she
says, what she does. Um, I think a lot
of her agenda aligns with that of the
Catholic Church.
>> Do do you think Christian nationalism
will be inflected by Catholicism when
when I am
Yeah. North America might have been
Catholic at the beginning uh at the
beginning of the conquest. That's for
sure. Sure. But this is a Protestant
country. But maybe that was the um 20th
century Christianity which was that
everyone was Protestant including the
Catholics and the Jews. They were just
another version of Protestantism. that
that's something that's older in fact
and is do you think Catholicism will be
the driving force of Christian
nationalism or or will it go more to a
Protestant fundamentalism?
>> Um I mean if you look at the situation
right now certainly the Catholic Church
and the Mormons have huge advantages but
as you say what matters is the soul of
this country. what what matters is what
what what Americans fundamentally
believe. And I think that Americans are
fundamentally
>> um anti-atholic church. They don't like
hierarchy. They don't like the idea of a
pope. Um they they I mean America's
America Americans fundamentally believe
in individualism and in liberty um and
direct access to to God. So um yeah, I
think the Catholic Church and the
Mormons have a huge advantage, but as
you say, what will actually happen, we
don't know. Also we have to remember
that this is a dynamic like the
situation is very dynamic and so we are
we we we're discounting geohysical
events like real real geohysical events
that could happen to America over the
next 20 years. I like like like I know
people um argue about climate change but
what what what we can't argue is that
the earth under goes extreme weather now
and then right you know we could be
facing a mini ice age in next next 20
years and if you have a mini ice age all
bets are off the table right because
like you you have a major depopulation
event so so it's a very dynamic
situation I'm not going to say the
Catholic Church will end up end up as
the winners I'm not going to say the
Protestants aren't end up as the winners
I think Christian theocracy is the end
result but which faction determines this
Christian theocyc I can't really say at
this point.
>> Interesting. Um Henry, you're next.
>> Yeah, a lot of the discussion lately has
been about the three Abrahamic religions
and for obvious reasons and potential
manifestation of their esquetology, but
I'm curious, how do you see the other
world religions playing into this event?
you know, the Buddhists perhaps have
less political influence, but the Hindus
and most interestingly the atheist
Chinese, like one big mystery for me is
what the relationship is between China
and Israel. So, I'm just curious how you
see that playing out.
>> Yeah, that's a great question. Um, so,
uh, I don't really know much about
Hinduism. I don't think it's it's
esqueological, right? I mean, like it's
it's like it's like Buddhism. It's not
esquetological in the way that the
Abrahamic religions are esquetological.
And that's important because it's
esquetolog esquetology that drives
geopolitics. It's esquetology that wants
you to like want you to go and like do
something in Jerusalem.
>> So, um I I do know a lot about China
because I obviously live in China and
I'm Chinese. Um China's not interested
in geopolitics. China is not interested
in what's happening in the Middle East.
It's interested in trade. It's
interested in exporting it cheap labor
overseas. Um but China's not g not not
going to militarily
intervene on anyone's behalf um outside
Chinese borders. It doesn't do that.
It's it's not going to invade Taiwan. I
know there's a lot of discussion that
China might use um all this upheaval
around the world to reclaim Taiwan.
China's not going to do that. It doesn't
have to do that. Um China is big enough
as it is. It's called the Middle Kingdom
because it sees itself as a universe
onto itself. It wants it wants to be
left alone basically. Um and and and and
that's that's the worldview of China.
We're the Middle Kingdom. Everyone else
is barbaric. They find themselves in the
Middle East. That's because what they
do, you know, that's that's what they
do. They just slaughter themselves like
like over there. Let's ignore it. Um you
know, I live in China and I check the
news every day and the Chinese are not
reporting what's happening
>> around the world. It's China's just not
interested in what's h happening in the
world. The other thing is that if you
just look at the economic situation in
China right now, it's very very
unstable. Um, and there's a real fear
that the economy will get worse and
worse. And I think the Communist Party
is more concerned about domestic unrest
than it is about, you know, overseas
wars.
>> So, it's it's interesting because you
learned English in Canada from the time
you were six. Do do you think that your
your worldview is obviously inflected by
your education and experience? But I I
think my impression is also that you're
really tapped into
social media and thinking in the west
and in America like you you I I presume
you're following Twitter in a way that
you're not looking at a Chinese
newspaper which which might be operating
in a different realm as you say.
>> Yeah. So um the messaging is more
controlled in China. So if you want to
know the official line then you read the
Chinese newspaper which will not take
very long. Um but it's but but if you
really want to understand the gist in
China, if you really want to understand
how people are thinking, you need to
walk streets, you need to see them in
restaurants, you you need to analyze
their faces. Um this is different in um
the west because social media I mean it
it's it's really like the id of of
America, right? I mean like just by
analyzing social media, you you get a
deep sense of the fundamental feelings
that are under underpinning American
society right now. And so I see a lot of
hatred. I see a lot of anger. I see a
lot of confusion. I see a lot lot lot of
anxiety.
>> Yeah, definitely.
Um Andrew J.
>> Hey, what's going on? Um I'm just
curious uh as far as like a next 911
moment, excuse me. Do you guys think
like a cyber security event like a
global or national or regional kind of
hacking event from another state like
Russia or even like a corporation could
kind of occur. Um I could see something
like that happening in the next 10 or so
years just because we're so on our
phones at this point where it seems to
me like fertile ground for some sort of
like terrorist attack. And then you have
the misinformation of oh that's a false
flag. it was really Israel who did it or
is, you know, I could see something like
that happen. Just want to uh get your
guys' take on that.
>> That's a fantastic question. Um so I say
that um 910 was like 9 911 and not not
in that like um Charter Kirk was
assassinated. What mattered was a
spectacle,
>> right? So after 911, what you saw on TV
all the time on constant, you know,
replay was the planes hitting the twin
towers and the twin towers coming down.
It was to induce trauma. You do that
through spectacle, through real life
spectacle, right? And so remember like
after the shooting that that graphic
video was unleashed on the internet,
everyone saw it. You didn't want to see
it. You just saw it by accident. And
guess what? It's stuck in your mind. And
that's going to have long-term
psychological consequences. It's going
to change the psych. It's going to
change the worldview. So that's what you
want to create. You want to create a
violent spectacle that traumatizes the
population. It hypn hypnotizes in a way
that allows allows you to program the
population in a way that you want.
Remember after 911, the Patriot Act was
was rammed through Congress and then
George Bush says, "We're gonna invade
Iraq." And people were never like, "Why
are we doing this?" like like like you
know because people were so shocked by
the event that they just sort of
passively accepted it and you know that
that's what trauma victims do like like
they just accept the world around them
because they've they've dis
disassociated from the world around them
right so the idea is to create a
spectacle so that that's why hacking
doesn't really do anything like like
like what like like how are you
traumatized if your computer goes off
for a week like like who cares right the
the point is to create a spectacle the
other thing that's really important is
that if you look at all major spectacles
of the past 20th century including the
killing of uh JFK, 911 and um Charlie
Kirk, you will see massive occult
symbolism around
the event, right?
>> So um uh Charlie Kirk was killed 33
weeks after the inauguration of Donald
Trump. He was killed 34 days before his
32nd birthday.
It took 33 hours for the FBI to capture
the culprit. The press conference lasted
33 minutes. The shooter was 22 years
old. I could go on and on, but it's all
programmed into the event to create a
subconscious fear and trauma. Um, I
mean, and I I mean I mean it's all
really well orchestrated. I mean, this
this this event must been like years in
the making. Maybe maybe they didn't know
it would be maybe they didn't pick the
victim yet, but they wanted to create a
911 spectacle in order to traumatize the
masses in order to push their agenda
further.
>> Fascinating. Do you think COVID was a a
kind of it wasn't a spectacle, but I'm
seeing in this hypothetical cyber
security event that I'm talking about
like a mass hacking or something like
that that I I was kind of thinking of
something like COVID where it was just
it was shocking but it was also, you
know, debilitating from your normal way
of life. That's I guess more so than a
911 kind of spectacle event like you're
saying.
>> Um yeah. Um, I think CO was an
experiment. I think like the situation
got out of control. Um, and they
responded. Um, and and and like in their
response, they recognized, oh my god,
the the masses are just sheep. They'll
just do whatever we tell them to do. Um,
and they got away with it. And so, I
think the next thing will be the actual
event, which is maybe implanting
microchips into your your bodies. That
that I think is is the real intention. I
think co might might have been an
experiment.
>> Um, regular guy.
>> So, you talk about this Christian
theocracy and the alternatives that it
could be. You said it could be Catholic,
it could be Protestant. You mentioned
the Mormons, which um that's kind of a
far cry to to what the typical American
is used to in terms of of theology. But
who do you think is when and you say you
say that's going to wrap up the conflict
in the US um that we're going to see.
Who is ultimately going to be the real
loser of this Christian the theocracy
and who's going to be the the winners?
Like is it going to be the common man
because they're going to be issued a
wife or is it going to be and are the
losers going to be non-heteronormative
people or is it going to be women
>> liberalism? Yeah.
>> Or just a or a atheist even if they're
white and male.
>> Yeah. So I don't see history as a
conflict between individuals and between
peoples. I see history as fundamentally
a conflict over ideas and narratives and
ideology. Right? So at the founding of
America, there was this ma there was
this major conflict between the
enlightenment ideal and the um Christian
utopia ideal, right? I mean remember
like the pilgrims came to America to
create a Christian utopia, the new
Jerusalem. And that sort of got
sidelined because of these enlightenment
ideals that have now man manifested
themselves into a multicultural
liberal
uh secular society and that I think will
be the real loser like you know goodbye
multiculturalism we don't want that we
want everyone to be Christian goodbye
secularism goodbye liberalism so so so I
mean the very idea of liberalism will uh
will die in this process I mean like
that's what I think is going to happen
>> I I think it yeah go on regular
>> I asked that because of um well in
addition to the enlightenment versus
Christian the theology in the US. There
was the uh slaver culture which we saw
emerge in the 19th century and the the
infamous mudillill speech which says
that you know society is hierarchical
and some people need to have tragic lots
where they need to be manual labors and
if we're not on top we might be at the
bottom of the mud still and I'm
wondering who would would be at the
bottom of the mud still in terms of
groups in this in the in this Christian
theoc democracy you see emerging?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. Um, and I
don't really see the sort of the
economic um, hierarchy changing that
much. I mean, like, you know, it's very
easy for these liberal elites to dawn on
new clothes, right? Like before they
were liberals and now they're just
priests. Like, what's the difference
really?
>> Um, what what they do behind closed
doors is their own business, right? But
what what they do in public uh I mean
they will pay adherence to the um
theocracy but you know behind closed
doors they'll still operate their secret
societies which will be liberal in in in
nature. So I don't really see the
economic hierarchy changing that much.
Hey um Richard I apologize but I need to
go because because I I have another call
at 11 o'clock. So
>> no problem.
>> Yeah we have really benefited from you
being here. I I definitely hope you can
come back on again. Uh because we just
we'll do this again.
>> Definitely. But uh thank you and uh
we'll we'll talk to you soon. Thank you.
>> Great. Thanks. So, okay. All right.
Thank you. Bye. Bye.
>> Bye.
>> All right. That was great stuff.